hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar cryogenic electron microscopy of
beam and air sensitive materials i am
jennifer woods of labyrinth and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by leica microsystems
to learn more visit leica hyphen
microsystems.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speakers dr
daniel long post doctoral appointee and
electron microscopist at sandia national
laboratories and dr john watt scientist
and electron microscopist
center for integrated nanotechnologies
or scent at los alamos national
laboratory daniel and john you may now
begin your presentation
thank you very much for the introduction
again my name is daniel long i'm from
sandia national labs at the
center for integrated nanotechnology
today i'll be talking about uh cryogenic
electron microscopy of beam and air
sensitive materials as it relates to
generally material science
and today's talk will be split in half
myself and then the other half will be
done by john watt my colleague from los
alamos national lab
brief outline of today's talk i'll talk
about the benefits of cryogenic electron
microscopy as it relates to material
science
then i'll give a
short introduction to preparing a liquid
liquid-solid interface uh for cryofib
and tem investigation
then i'll talk specifically
about a tem experiment or
sorry a tm
investigation of calcium metal anode
battery that i've been involved in
recently
and then once those three topics are
finished john will talk about cryo-ems
soft matter
so the
sorry
the benefits of cryo-electron microscopy
are many i've listed quite a few on the
right that's not fully exhausted but
when it when it pertains to material
science it's especially important for
sample preparation and sample imaging
you can see on the left here this is a
fib cross section
of a lithium metal substrate you can see
at room temperature the fib cross
section has a lot of remnant damage
whereas at room at cryogenic
temperatures it's nice it's nice and
clean so there's a lot less
ion beam damage with when you cool the
sample
when it comes to electron beam damage
say in the tem
let's say we're looking at lithium
dendrites a lithium metal dendrite you
can see in the top left image that that
is a slightly corroded lithium metal
dendrite
that has uh holes in it that
forms
that formed during high high resolution
imaging whereas on the bottom the
lithium dendrite is
fully metallic throughout the thickness
of the sample and you can image it to
atomic resolution fairly readily so it's
really nice for that
also great for reducing ion beam
artifacts
such as alloying embrittlement or
hydrogenation
and here's an example on the left of
an aluminum
and aluminum grain boundary looking at
the chemical composition across that
grain boundary and on the left part of
the
on the left part of the figure you can
see that aluminum sorry that gallium has
implanted itself between these two
grains
on the right side of the figure the
gallium has not preferentially
embedded itself within the grain
boundary so it's very useful for those
kinds of studies
also great for
stabilizing organics
nanoparticles those sorts of things so
here's a
fracture cross section of a hydro
hydrated microgel this is kind of
similar to the work that john will be
showing at the
his half of the talk
and then one of the most important
things that cryo cryogenic electron
microscopy allows us to do is to look at
liquid solid interfaces and when i say
liquid solid i mean a vitrified liquid
and against a solid interface and here's
an example of
some of my work where i looked at a
a
surfactant solution against a mica
substrate looking at how the surfactant
solution behaves at that substrate these
are great for
especially for
batteries modern batteries
that have liquid solvent
liquid electrolytes other devices with
trapped or flowing liquid as well as
liquid storage
and a little bit more flavor of my work
um
i primarily work in the uh energy
storage areas so i've looked at uh
single-use lithium-ion battery anode and
cathodes i've looked at
lithium-metal anode batteries on the
bottom left
i've looked at multivalent metal anode
batteries specifically calcium and
magnesium on the top right
and then i've also looked at the
aqueous mica interfaces
so how do we prepare these interfaces
it's a complicated process
and i broke it down into 10 steps here
and it can be broken down in various
different ways but the first step is
vitrification
of your liquid solid interface
and i've have two examples
the top example is showing a
circular calcium deposit on a
gold coated
silicon substrate and those are
generally vitrified in
liquid nitrogen
the the higher molecular weight of the
electrolytes allows you to to
cool the sample more slowly and still
vitrify the electrolyte whereas on the
bottom
i have a image of a mica h2o
sample setup and those need to be
vitrified in a vitrobot
or in liquid ethane
then the samples are
transferred into our leica cryogenic
suite
and that involves our load station which
is underneath the title there and that
load station has a shuttle attached on
the left side
and we
use that shuttle to move the
sample between the load station our
sputter coating station which is on the
bottom right
and then our fib sem which is on the top
right there
third step is to protect the lithium i'm
assuming that this is assuming that the
lifts are not lithium the liquid is the
top uh
top layer of your sample
and so the way that this is done in
cryogenic uh bib sem
is by a
blanket coating so the sample is fully
cooled to cryogenic temperatures
the gas injection system needle is
retracted several millimeters and the
set point is changed to room temperature
and then it's open the flow is open for
on the order of 10 seconds to a minute
and then it's cured with the ion beam
now this is a black box solution it's
not as
good as the room temperature fib
platinum coating so you do have to
tune the parameters so that you get well
cured and fully dense
platinum coating
and
this is uh this is
great for
this is great for protecting that
liquid layer on top because that liquid
layer is generally going to be the most
beam sensitive component of your sample
moving on to uh steps four five and six
uh
you need to locate your region of
interest now when it's coated with
a vitrified liquid typically your
surface is not going to have a lot of
features as you can see on the left
image
in the top right part of the left image
it's mostly flat with a few
features kind of poking through and so
it's difficult to
locate where you are in the sample so i
recommend correlating
uh
the sem images to
an optical image or a fluorescence image
that you've taken prior to uh going into
the scm and then five and six uh i
bought a bunch together i call that just
a standard sid milling so you do your
trenches um
kind of your you're cleaning up the
trenches preparing for the j cut of the
fib lift out and this process is highly
sample dependent it will depend on
the density of your solid phase the
density of your liquid phase and how
much
and the quality of your fib platinum cap
on top
so before you do the j cut
you need to protect the back side of the
lamella assuming that you have a liquid
phase present
that liquid phase will damage very
easily when you've tilted the sample to
zero to the tilt of the stage to zero
degrees
so what i recommend doing is
uh doing a reduced area in the yellow uh
dashed box area and just letting that
run for a minute or two and that will
redeposit
a few hundred nanometers of material
onto the back and this is important for
uh when you do the j-cut you have to
image
that backside
then the next step is attaching the
needle and i've shown here a
redeposition attachment and so you can
see the needle is on the right there
on the right image it's the bottom left
part of the image is the needle and then
the sample is the majority of the middle
of the image and there's lines kind of
connecting the two parts
and the way that that's done is
be a little bit of a complicated process
but if you can imagine visualizing the
the lift out needle
on the left there you have your lamella
and your new or your unprepared lift out
needle generally they're round
when you buy them or you install them
and so what we need to do is
is to flatten the front side of that
lamella needle before making contact
with it and then once that's flattened
you can go ahead and make contact and
then i use
thin rectangular patterns that
that i mill through the
through the needle and then into the
sample and that creates a redeposition
connection and i'll move those patterns
sequentially outward as
you can see here
and i've included a video of this
process
so i'll go ahead and talk over this
video a little bit
so i'm moving the needle into position
this is my
sample my region of interest already
chosen my trenches my trenches are
are cut my j cut is cut
so i'm putting my little patterns there
i'm going to bring the needle
into contact
and this is sped up by 10x i am not the
set
so i'll let those two patterns move and
then i'll move them outwards
taking sequentially sequentially taking
images
of the connection with the e-beam
then doing a little bit of an extra
pattern and
then there's my connection then i'll cut
the rest of the j cut
and the sample is completely free
and then i'll lift it out
and so this is a great method for for
doing cryoliftout you can also use
you can read you can
put down more uh
fib platinum it does
charge if you don't cure it so that's
one issue to think about and also put
down ice if your fib system has that
available but again that will also
charge so i like to do the three
deposition cut
and once you have it onto the needle the
next step
is to put it onto
the step grid
so the fig grids that we're using are a
copper fib half grid that's attached to
a molybdenum slot grid and that
molybdenum slot grid gives us a good
handle
to manipulate the sample when it's under
when we're loading it under liquid
nitrogen
so i'm bringing the sample into contact
made contact i'm just gonna
i like to thin the needle till it's
almost nothing left right before i
make
contact then i'll use a regular cross
section with the beginning
of the pattern
so the bottoms of these patterns
towards the sample and that redeposits
material backwards into that and then
i'll cut the needle free
and then once i have that
that needle free i'll go to 52 degrees
and i will anchor down the other side
and generally when i do the lamellae
anchors i kind of do an angular
distribution around the side
and what i'm looking for is to see that
kind of the like the bottom of the
sample start to flare outward
indicating that i've got lots of
redeposit redeposited material there
okay so then once that's done and i'm
happy with uh how rigid my sample is
connected to the
um to the grid then i'd move on to final
thinning
there are this is one method of
attachment this is on top of a fib post
you can also attach
in the v-notch of your fit grid
if you prefer that and here's just some
other images of me doing that you can
also do it in flag in the flagpole
position as well and it's the same
general principle that use the
redeposition to make the connection
so then the last step is final thinning
this is highly sample dependent i've
shown
three images kind of progress through
one of my
thinning
procedures and you can see the contrast
of each layer changes throughout the
throughout the process and so it's
very important that you understand how
the contrast changes with your material
especially if you have something like an
electrolyte that's
very low z or an organic that's low z or
you're working with lithium or something
like that
and in general i like to use the low
voltages the ion voltages of eight five
and two a lot more than i traditionally
do in room temperature prep
and i can generally get these samples to
be about 50 nanometers thick
pretty much every time i get a good lift
out done
okay so then we're going to switch gears
so now that i've got
that kind of laid out for you i'll talk
about one of the which projects that i'm
involved with which is again calcium
metal anode and this this work was
funded by j caesar that's the joint
center for energy storage research
and this is in collaboration with scott
mcclary and kevin zabadel
so briefly uh lithium-ion batteries are
current uh the current kind of dominant
uh energy storage uh especially mobile
energy storage they're typically
composed of an anode that is coated with
graphite and then the
cathode is coated with
transition metal oxide uh lithium-cobald
oxide or other
alloys of that and then they're
separated by a polymer separator and
then that's infilled with the liquid
electrolyte
um however as we
continue to increase our energy demand
say from mobile devices to cars to home
storage to grid storage
we have kind of a fundamental issue with
continuing to use lithium batteries and
that is that lithium batteries with
their carbon-based anodes have a
reasonable but small
capacity energy capacity
and especially in in addition to that
they also have a
a low uh natural abundance compared to
some of these rock forming elements when
we look at these rock forming elements
things like calcium aluminum sodium and
magnesium
all have much higher natural abundances
and then if you go to the middle you can
also see that their theoretical
volumetric capacities
are also much greater than
than current lithium-ion technology so
we have to ask ourselves how far we can
really take these lithium-ion batteries
so recently i think it was 2018
there was a
the first uh publication of a room
temperature
recyclable calcium metal anode battery
and since then there's been a a whole
bunch of publications that have followed
along after that
and these are all great
that this is possible and that we can
study the system now and we can include
this in our kind of our research
repertoire but there is the we also need
to realize that we need uh very high
column efficiencies greater than 99
for practical
rechargeable batteries
and these rechargeable batteries require
a very ideal
type of sei or solid electrolyte
interface
and a very ideal deposit morphology we
don't want anything that's going to
throw dendrites or throw in a very
structured
manner that could puncture a battery
and so here's what that ideal
battery might look like it'd have a
continuous sei
that would only allow for the metal to
transport across it wouldn't allow for
any solvent or anion
transport and it would not allow for
electron transport either
and then that ideal battery would also
have a fully dense
if we're talking about metal anode
battery a fully dense metal anode that
is uh relatively flat and well behaved
so that first paper that i showed
they did some sem
on their calcium deposits and they found
what they believe was a calcium hydride
phase in their sei
and that's okay that's pretty good
because
another group modeled the
migration barriers of
both calcium and magnesium metal anode
sei component
and they found
if you look on the left there mh2 that's
the metal hydride that they have very
low migration energy barriers which is
great
great news for
an sei component however this was
a few years old and this this
experiment on the right here is a few
years old and they didn't necessarily
use really inert
methods to look at this and so we need
to
restudy reinvestigate this
this material system this electrolyte
that they specifically use as well with
cryogenic and inert methods
so briefly we used a teflon t-cells
with a calcium counter and reference
electrode and we deposited onto gold
textured working electrodes
our electrolyte was the same as the
paper that we previously showed
which is a calcium borohydride salt with
a little bit of sodium borohydride salt
that are both solvated in thf
solvent
and looking at a plan view of these
deposits they look pretty dense there's
a few pockets of porosity but for the
most part they're completely dense we
deposit them to a few hundred nanometers
thickness
just because we're interested in
early stages of growth and nucleation
xrd confirms
what the other authors have found that
they have
primarily hcp and fcc phases of calcium
metal
and we had trace amounts
of calcium hydride as well
and so this is all kind of
gelling together into one nice story
however xrd
is not
spatially resolved here we need to
understand how that works that's why we
included cryofib and cryotem into this
effort
so i'm going to skip through all the
private fib preparation
and jump right into the tem
result
so on the left is
a bright field image of a
craig fib liftout lamella of these
battery systems
and you can see
you can see that the deposit is
completely dense we do have electrolyte
present at the top of the image it's a
little bit cut off here
but there is
electrolyte presence as well it's fairly
textured you can see kind of linear
linear uh features on the right side
going from the gold electro electrode to
the top
and if we look at a selected area
diffraction pattern on the right we have
lots of rings that when we index they
index to hcp and fcc calcium so this is
all consistent and there's also a a
diffuse calcium oxide ring hidden in
there as well which we believe is
on the front and back of the lamella and
that's just some trace oxidation
but what this uh diffraction pattern
tells us
is that
one we have a very textured deposit
which is
to be expected with a
textured electrode but we also have
plentiful a lot of stacking faults and
that's evident in streaking the
diffraction pattern that
can be expected when you have a dual fcc
htc phase system
when we look at this with stem
something pops out to us we see these uh
these nuggets of
interesting contrast this different
porosity near the gold electrode
and when we
take a selected area diffraction pattern
from those regions specifically we find
calcium hydride reflection
so what this is telling us is that
calcium hydride at least the majority of
what we're finding is located near the
gold electrode
so that leads us to our next
investigation which is a chemical
investigation using an electron energy
loss spectroscopy to look at
the chemical fingerprints across
this deposit
so we looked at this region of interest
that includes the hydride which i've
outlined here
in yellow
and what we did is we did low loss
eels mapping and then we applied
principal component analysis
and pulled out the principal components
and then mapped them
and what we found was we have four
principal components we have the metal
component hydride component electrolyte
component and the sei
you notice that the sei and hydride are
distinctly different they do have
similarities but they are distinctly
different
when we map those components what we see
is that the sei which is located where
you'd expect it on the surface of the
middle
maps is green here is not showing up in
the hydride and the hydride is not
showing up in the sci
when we move to four loss fields
a similar story evolves this time we
have five principal components that's
just because
the electrolyte uh split off into a
carbon rich and a boron rich
component when we map them
same story
same picture arises hydride is
distinctly different than the sei and
these are mapped at 10 nanometers per
pixel we do have higher
spatial resolution maps while they
confirm this
when we zoom into the oxygen edge of the
top three components
seen the green component the sei that
it's oxygen rich compared to the other
two and so this is kind of pointing us
in the direction that this is a calcium
oxide
phase that's present
so when we image this it's probably hard
to see on your screen here but i'll go
ahead and outline it
we divided this image
into metallic calcium at the top and
interphase region in our electrolyte
region
and zooming in on little spots in
metallic calcium
we have
atp as well as fcc that i didn't show
lattice spacing
in the interphase we have lots of oxide
lots of oxide
lattice fringes and so this is pretty
strong evidence that um
both the the sei is both fully
heterogeneous because we have these
different orientations
and it's confirmed to be calcium oxide
likely with some carbonates and boron
present
so where that leaves us is a picture
like this
we have
only calcium hydride
domains near the gold electrode which
is is okay
because i'll show you in a second the
heterogeneous calcium oxide also has a
somewhat manageable
migration barrier you can see here the
mo it's the red mo it is higher than the
hydride but it's not as high as the
magnesium case
and so these are
ongoing research studies that we're
doing
and and uh we will be publishing this uh
briefly
and then with that uh i'd like to
acknowledge again scott for
sample generation and the
electrochemistry and paul catulla for
helping with
data collection
and data analysis
and also thank
jay caesar for funding this work
and with that i will turn it over to
john
all right
thank you dan um thank you for
first off the talk so my name is john
watt um i'm also at the center for
integrated nanotechnology um i'm also at
los alamos national laboratory
so i'm going to shift gears here a
little bit and talk and talk about uh
cryogenic electron microscopy for soft
matter material
so obviously cryo has seen a huge
explosion recently
most
mostly in structural biology where
they're really pushing the resolution
limits you know for structural biology
and solving the structures of protein
and you know here is a very high
resolution image of the covered spike
protein
so here the goal is
along with most tdm is to increase
resolution
and they do this with very high
accelerating voltages and aberration
correction
but unfortunately when you do that you
dress you drastically reduce contrast
this is an issue with these types of low
z samples
as you need some contrast to see things
um so
to counteract this um
these are suspended in a vitreous ice
background um
also playing with things like defocus
and space plates and also taking many
hundreds and thousands of images
of the protein so on the right there you
can see you know a typical kind of
single image of a protein sample in
crayoem
each individual structure is
fairly difficult to see
with with fairly low contrast but you
reconstruct thousands of those images
together and all
get your you get your structure
um and since since the integrated
nanotechnologies we're really interested
in material science and nanotechnology
so we uh are using crayom for a
different um sample space
and that soft matter so things like
polymer vesicles micelles
microtubules nanoparticles
nano nanoparticles polymer composites
even things like metal organic
frameworks
so soft matter has historically seen
limited analysis by transmission
electron microscopy um due to a few
inherent problems
one
is that it gets damaged by the electron
beam
it's a soft matter
it also has an instability under a high
vacuum environment this is especially
true if it's hydrated or solvated
to look at it you typically have to drop
cast onto a grid
and then dry off the solvent and that
gives you a lot of drain artifact and
uncertainty in your structure
um to
counteract the low contrast of you know
carbon against the carbon film
background
traditionally uh folks will use negative
staining technique
there's something like urinal acetate
and it's an image uh typical image on
the top right there
so you get good contrast but here again
you have drying artifacts and also now
you've put in a very heavy metal into
your sample
and so it introduces more uncertainty
into the structure
so analysis of soft matter has been
dominated
by ensembl scattering techniques so two
of the main ones are dynamic like
gathering dialys
and small angle x-ray scattering
stacks so
two examples here
in the graph but these are very useful
but they're also
they average across the entire ensemble
so they don't give you a real space
image and also
you know they're based upon a model
um so we really want to see a real space
image that doesn't have all of these
drying artifacts and staining artifacts
and soft matter research
so just a few examples of synthetic
organic matter structures from the
literature and what they look like in
crayoem
on the left there we have liposome um
with citrate stabilized gold
nanoparticles and you can see
the gold nanoparticles have very good
contrast as we would expect
and then looking at the liposome
if you look at it against the uh the
vitreous ice background so if we look at
frame f
you can see against the victorious ice
we have good contrast but as the
structure kind of overlaps with the
carbon substrate you see we lose that
contrast so really keeping these in the
bacterial site is our best chance of
seeing the structure
another couple of examples uh cross
blank center bubbles for fluorocarbon
and then also you know nanoparticle
polymer conjugate so these are
polyacrylic acids polystyrene brush
grafts and silicon
some of the examples
from scent is a quantum dot polymer
nanocomposite so these are from safety
compound at uc irvine
so we can see you know the structure of
the quantum dots within this uh
nanocomposite and then also against the
petrocytes we can see the polymer and
make out the shell there
on the right hand side we have silicon
nanoparticles that have a lipid coating
this is professor neridine from
university of new mexico
and when we use lower accelerating
voltage high contrast imaging um we can
resolve see
at least the uh visible lipid on the
surface and so you know these kinds of
things are really uh unique to crayoen
we would have put this into a high
accelerating voltage dry tm if we just
want to see that that lipid layer
uh so the scent crayon sweet and
dan kind of touched on a few of these
tools but i'll just get an overview of
what we have and some of the unique
capability
so this is a microscopy suite dedicated
to minimizing electron dose for the
imaging of materials and their
interfaces
and their native hydrated all solvated
states we've actually recently done some
experiments with with toluene freezing
toluene
providing our user community with
optimized characterization of sensitive
materials across multiple length scales
and it's actually the the leica
equipment that really helps us to cross
those multiple ways
so within this week we have a vitrobot
so that's for um consistent and
reproducible plunge freezing and we have
the the style focused imb milling sem
and then we also have a dedicated
kalos l120c cryocem um so you know this
this lab has been set up for the
soft matter and so this telos is a low
accelerating voltage but very high
contrast tool um so mitigate as much
beam damage as possible
or giving us really good contrast and
resolution
but it's the cryo stage um and transfer
equipment that really kind of ties the
whole suite together so the the bryo is
the end stage goes on style and then the
transfer equipment enables us
to have all the tools brought together
and this gives us uh imaging capability
for biomimetic materials polymers
nanocomposites and interfaces
and also as dan was presenting you know
low z system
um so the the lyco cryo workflow
it really is a complete and robust
workflow so we have the virtualbox and
then we have the bcm
um so this is where we can you know
transfer in our frozen samples
and we can manipulate them we can load
them into the shuttle
then we can put them into the a600 which
is a cryogenically called sputter coder
um and then you know as dan has shown we
can go between the sdm and the tm we've
prepared lamella
and that's done on the vcm where these
uh
you see the the dark spots on the right
hand side a side port where you can put
a side entry tem holder and then do your
transfer completely under alien2 so the
nice thing about this system is that
once your sample is frozen it never
again sees ambient condition you can do
all of your work under allen2 or under
vacuum
as well as all transfers
so just to briefly go over
the
kind of steps of plunge breathing so if
you're looking at something like a
protein or a vesicle or a nanoparticle
that's hydrated and suspended in
solution
you would do kind of typical plunge
freezing in the vitrobot
um and so
here what you do is you take a holy
carbon grid
which has a carbon substrate and then
for the force
you would apply your sample
uh and so this is the sample solution so
if well suspended by molecules
if you were to freeze that then
obviously you would have
that the electron beam could not see
through
so you
work away the excess liquid the filter
paper
and the idea is that the
solution will flow into the pores and
you will just wash away the excess
you then plunge freeze into ethane
which has very good thermal transport
properties
and then you will have a well suspended
uh
sample
within that vitreous size which is kind
of things of nanometers thick so just
looking at this cross section you see
that you know you do have some d
variation in your in your structure
which you don't necessarily have with
dry cem
so that can you know give you some
uncertainty and um orientation but also
focus
so this is great for something that is
um you know a small part of a 12-person
solution
but for bulk materials if you're
preparing for
uh you know for fit
then this can not be the best cannot
always be the best option
because you know it's quite thick and
also that means it might not hold on to
the squeezers
it might not fit the whole system
and the other thing
or polymers that we've found is that
they can be very brittle under alien two
and so trying to kind of mount them and
to manipulate them after they've frozen
um you can kind of just shatter them it
can be quite difficult um so one method
that we found works pretty well is to
mount the sample
at room temperature
and then just freeze the whole the whole
set up so on the left-hand side there um
the the brass um kind of shuttle at the
bottom
of the leica equipment and then we have
a modified food set up on the top there
with our footprint our first half grip
mounted
and then an sem stuff with a clamp and
so the idea is that
you would prepare this outside and then
sponge freezer since the laser than the
vcm
uh if it's hydrated then
um you know as long as it's not going to
dry out over the course of 20 30 seconds
as you get ready to plunge then it's
usually okay and working away a little
bit of excess moisture with a kimwipe
can mean that you have um you know less
ice formation on the surface
so i'll move to the next slide to show
these videos
in full screen
so here we are just untreating the whole
setup
and waiting for it to stop bubbling
and then this is using the vct
you'll see the gravity will come in
grab the shuttle
pull it back
user facility so some of the most
exciting work that we do is with our
users so i'm just going to go over a few
examples here of how the cryo
uh suite and the leica workflow have
really impacted user science um so the
first example
is with professor ben wiley from duke
university
and so this work was looking at an
artificial cartilage hydrogel
that's strong enough to work in need
so they had a biome
approach
to create the first hydrogel with the
same strength and modulus as human
articular cartilage and compression and
tension
the bacterial cellulose nanofiber
network
with a polyvinyl alcohol and propane
sulfonic acid
sodium salt
was formed into a double network
hydrogel that exhibited a coefficient of
friction about half that of cartilage it
was more resistant to wear than cba and
showed
fatigue strength equivalent to cartilage
at very high number of cycles
so it was a cellulose that provided skin
cell strength and the men are analogous
to the cartilage
while the pamp is provided affects
negative charge
similar to the role of agriculture
cartilage and it was able to balance a
very heavy load
and so we were able to image this on uh
using the cryo sdm so this was just
freezing in alien2 and then transferring
to the sem and so here we're seeing the
distribution of the the fibers
without any kind of
drain artifacts that would be
inherent and normally
another example and this is an example
of pro fib liftout and lamellar
preparation of of the polymer
so this is with a scent user and
collaborator from the university of new
south wales
and here they made tungsten polyviral
films pacific capacitors
and they wanted to look at the
distribution of function aggregates
within the poly chiral matrix
so here we made really good use of the
vcm this is a very thin film
that
became quite brittle under railing blue
so we mounted it first and then and then
froze it
and then you'll see in figure a that we
made
you know outfit cut as as dan had kind
of shown um polymers can can melt very
fast so again each sample is different
and you have to kind of tune your
conditions
um then we did a list out and the
standard kind of flag orientation of the
lamella
and then and then
you'll see in panel c that there's quite
a bit of
ice contamination so this is actually
one of one of our earliest goes at a
polymer liftout
and
there was quite a bit of contamination
but we've since got very bit uh we've
since gone a lot better at doing
things like heating our nitrogen lines
during surge cycle
can actually go a long way to reducing
condensation
and ice and you'll see in panel d uh you
know we do resolve those chunks and
aggregate so you know this resolution is
on the order of nanometers
which is pretty good for a polymer on in
a low contrast right and a low
accelerating voltage
this is kind of again repeating what dan
showed but just showing that for the
soft matter for polymer you know
attaching the needle the same things
ring true you know you want very good
contact between the needle and the
polymer um when you're making
your attachment cuts and your re-dip
cuts you've got to be
aware that the polymer mill is
incredibly fast
so you have to be careful you've done
all that work to to make the fib cuts
and bring the needle in
you know you kind of have to go slow and
make sure that you're not completely
destroying your sample
before you get a chance to attach it but
then we do a little bit of platinum
cure it and then lift out
another thing that's really interesting
about cryo-em is that um it can be used
on things that aren't necessarily
hydrated and don't necessarily need to
be kept cold from the sample itself
um so this is where uh collaborator
instant user thing change from los
alamos national laboratory
but here they grew some zinc oxide nano
rods
on a zinc oxide substrate
with a 2d molybdenum disulfide
interlayer and the goal here is to
preserve that sensitive foodist layer
which when the lookout was being done in
room temperature they were seeing that
get destroyed
so on the right hand side there you'll
see the cut
but this was an interesting challenge
because i had the mill from the front to
find the rod and then
mill from the back so that i could keep
that rod intact any further milling from
the front meant that i would lose that
and i would have to find another one
so this was all performed at you know at
cryogenic temperatures minus 150c
you'll see on the left when we don't
have our milling condition um right that
that sensitive interface gets destroyed
and you get a void formation
um and then on the right you'll see
when we have our
milling conditions right we're at cold
temperatures and we're being very
careful with the sample you know we
maintain that sensitive interface
uh and this is just taking that same
sample through scanning transmission
electron microscopy
and you'll see on the left you'll see
you know the platinum the rod and i'm
also looking at the platinum deposition
that middle layer you'll see that it's
not uh
you know beautifully uniform because we
did get some shadowing from the rods and
so you had to place some tricks to make
sure that you've got
good platinum dip
around the rod
and then
as we increase the magnification we can
see that we did
maintain that sensitive insulator
so cent is a user facility uh we're
funded by the the coe department of
energy um so access to our facilities
and scientific expert
expertise is free so access to this
crawling lab is free for non-proprietary
research
it just requires a the submission and
acceptance of a two-page user proposal
so to learn more about the facilities
please visit student.lanos.gov
so we are supported by the doe and we
are hosted by both sandia national
laboratories
and los alamos national laboratories
um and if you had any more questions
about about the the cryolab
um about you know cryo food liftout
or the analysis of matter under crayons
please don't hesitate to contact myself
or dan um i'd also like to thank my
colleague uh katie young yahan
has been the national average
thank you daniel and john for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you would
like to ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
for daniel
do you protect the backside again to
make the j cut
that's a good question uh so what i do
is with the sample tilted to the ion
beam at 52 degrees
i place a pattern on the back side of
the sample that's the side you can't see
with the electron beam
i'll place the pattern and it'll just be
a raster pattern or a random pattern and
i'll let it mill on the trench itself
not hitting the sample but just on the
trench itself and that will re-deposit
the material onto the back side and
that's important because when you do the
j-cut you have to image the backside
so if you have a very sensitive sample
you're going to be damaging that
backside
thank you
daniel let's see the next question is
for john
what are some of the biggest challenges
for liftout of polymers and soft matter
thanks um yeah quite quite a few
actually um i i guess as dan alluded to
earlier you know for each sample it's
very dependent
uh on the nature of the material for you
know things like milling rates
um and it's not just for you know making
the cuts but
but also things like redeposition
for soft matter redeposition can be
quite a challenge
um also you know
artifacts from the ion beam um into your
cuts are quite important
uh during thinning um you can actually
get the lamella curl up on itself maybe
a lot quicker than you would for say
some kind of inorganic material just
because of a
it's not so rigid
and i would say in cryo one of the
challenges
um
as the matter gets as the sample gets a
little bit more sensitive is
you know dan showed we have to use a lot
of these
kind of redeposition techniques for
attachment because we can't use you know
defined platinum welds
that a lot of the redep from soft matter
it's it's not as controlled and so um
you know you might need to rely on
re-dip from the needle or re-depth from
the platinum protective layer
in order to get those um those
connections
thank you john our next question is for
daniel again
how long does it take to prepare a fib
lamella of a vitrified liquid solid
interface and also a polymer soft
material
yeah that's a good question um
so it depends on the size of the lamella
that you're making generally i make a
fairly large lamella
about 20 to 30 microns wide
that just that gives me a
greater opportunity to get a good region
of the sample
but
i'd say in general it'll take you the
better part of a full work day to make a
cryogenic lamella
whereas in room temperature you could do
that in a in a morning or an afternoon
all right thank you daniel let's see
next question is for john
what type of tem cryoholder and tem is
used are used and how about the
stability of it can you do eels mapping
yeah that's a great question too being
you know kind of the the end point of
all of this work right so you you know
you do a lot of work to do the cryofib
lift out you do the transfer and then
yeah if you're if your hold is not
stable then
it wasn't really worth doing the the
sample prep so
all of this work was done using the
gatan 626 so kind of the classic
cryo holder for an fei or thermo fisher
microscope but
really whichever one
you know you have in your lab
so we use the 626 i know gatan has the
the elsa
now which is used more for tomography
and has better stability and tomography
um there has been some ills mapping i
think dan
has done some eels mapping so yeah this
is all possible just just depending on
on what setup you have
for your tm
at the end case but yeah absolutely
having confidence in your
team holder and the transfer
is absolutely critical to you know want
to put in a day or two days of sample
prep
all right thank you john
next question is for daniel
well the cryo experiments on tem cause
contamination or other
or another issue to the tem
uh another good question um so generally
when the tem holder and your sample are
cold it will act as a
contamination trap and it will
in general improve the vacuum of the dem
but if you do have something that
sublimates or spotters really easily
something carbonaceous organic
in theory it could
slightly contaminate but it's not likely
it's more likely to
clean up the vacuum
all right thank you daniel
our next question is for john
how do you think aiml will impact the
structural biology
uh yeah that's that's that's quite a
quite a heavy question um
it's kind of a little bit outside my
my sphere but um i i imagine that will
be a huge factor going forward in
structural biology especially when they
are trying to push the resolution you
know more to the sub angstrom level and
also i guess the goal would be to
you know reduce the
as they start to build these training
data sets on
you know particles that have been
resolved to high resolution
you can start to reduce some of the
acquisition times
that are needed you know tens of
thousands of images that are combined um
perhaps am i a aiml can start to reduce
you know the the the time with the
microscope which is obviously labor
intensive and um you know microscope
intensive and costly
all right thank you next question here
is for daniel
is there advice on ice contamination
during transfer to the tem for battery
materials after fib and how long do you
take out the sample from fib and bring
it to the tem
yeah so that's that is a difficult part
of the process um it's the one that we
had to spend a lot of time in our
process development on
but in general my advice
for
for transfer between fib and tem is to
keep it
keep it under liquid nitrogen if that's
okay keep it under liquid nitrogen for
as long as possible
and minimize any of the
the nitrogen gas exposures such as when
you load it physically into the tip of
the dem
make those as quick as possible and
these are steps that take a lot of
practice a lot of manual
fine motor skills
and then
the other part the other question was
how long between the two microscope
for us we'd like to do it the same day
if possible but
often what happens is we spend the whole
first day of the experiment doing the
cryofib and lift out and thinning and
then we'll store it in liquid nitrogen
in a i think it's a 35 liter
liquid nitrogen storage door
overnight
and
so between generation analysis it's
sometimes it's up to 24 hours
all right thank you daniel next question
is for john
how do you transfer the air sensitive
sample to the tem
yeah that's that's that's a good
question too that's um a very critical
step so
uh i can't recall dan if in your slides
you showed the glove box attachment but
um what we also have is the vct the
sample transfer
um
unit well we have a flange on the side
of the glove box so traditionally uh you
know if people are trying to transfer
air sensitive samples they will
put it in a you know basically in a
mason jar and then put that in a bag and
then you know run that down the hall
quickly open it up
um and pump down uh the sem with minimal
exposure um but we can put the vct
directly on the flange which goes into
the glove box so we can do things like
open
open coin cells
uh under argon and then transfer them
under vacuum and cold
so you know it can be under high vacuum
and then we can cool it down even more
to increase their vacuum
and then
put that onto the sem so that's one of
the really nice things about the the
leica system is
you know your sample can never ever see
ambient conditions which is which is
really nice
thank you john we have one last question
here and it is for daniel
for one cryo tem eels work how long does
it take usually double the dormer excuse
me double the normal stem eels and do
you have a cryo tem holder that also has
an air free function
uh so for cryo eels the main time
constraint is
drift correction
obviously with the tem holder the the 66
that we use
it drifts at i think it's about a
nanometer per second or a little bit
less
but we do have to use heavy drift
correction
um and that adds i think it's about
20
of the total uh acquisition time so if
you have a
uh 25 minute acquisition it'll add
another five to ten minutes onto it and
then um
we don't have an
inert cryo
trans uh tem holder we just have the
uh cryo the guitar 626 and i forget what
the other model is but we have a single
tilt and a double tilt and both are just
cryogenic holders but i know that some
other
institutions have the
vacuum and the cryo capability
so i will add on that though that you
know the the cryo holder does have the
frost shield which even though it's not
you know air free it does give you
you know a little bit more time
to transfer a sample
yeah absolutely and we've transferred
lithium calcium all of sodium various uh
reactive metals and
very minimal if not equivalent to a
vacuum transfer holder
great well thank you again dr daniel
long and dr john watt for your time
today and for your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor leica microsystems for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time goodbye